no no dimmi che non sono aquile
dimmi che non solo aquile dimmi che non
sono varie dimmi che sono tornate alle
fa fa ciò che gli spetta li faccio
vedere io mi tocca vero lo sapevo
bird e nick due esiste per davvero ma ve
lo ricordate il primo video di per the
mic era veramente la merda se non ho mai
capito il successo che ebbe quelli dole
perché mi fa di uno schifo perché è
incompleta impacciata avrei potuto dire
mille cose non ne ho detta una giusta ma
nonostante tutto ebbe un buon successo
per i tempi almeno e molta gente che sta
guardando questo video lo sta guardando
grazie a quella recensione lì quindi
grazie per aver tenuto duro tutti questi
anni quando venni a sapere che ci
sarebbe stato un bio devi il duo detto
perché il primo è finito così bene ed è
riuscito addirittura un sito dove
c'erano degli obiettivi per esempio se
pagare i 15 dollari che arrivava al dvd
20 che arrivava il blu ray 25 la
maglietta e scena anche l'opzione tipo
non mi ricordo mi sembra 30 40 dollari
che si arrivava anche il pupazzo
dell'aquila dove tu potevi a metterle al
braccio vento e fare tipo marionetta e
c'era anche la versione da 100 dollari
dove il maestro in cui m il regista del
primo film ti poteva dare una lezione di
regia su skype ma il sito non so quando
e stato cancellato
strano quindi dobbiamo godere della
versione dvd normale questo che ci
crediate o no è verde ming 2 il film
inizia con il logo della casa di
produzione che si traduce in ciò un
pesce sono felice per voi ma neanche il
tempo di dire vado a suicidarmi che
veniamo catapultati ad hollywood
yeah a casa di grandi attori registi e
camminatori incalliti
sì una delle attività preferite del
nostro protagonista e camminare in mezzo
ai titoli di testa per minuti interi no
per davvero
ci sono cinque minuti di orologio
contati dove lui cammina cammina cammina
oh mi raccomando non fate vedere sto
pezzo di film ai tedeschi che poi rubano
l'idea per un simulatore finalmente
raggiunge un locale dove deve incontrare
un paio di amici ma prima
un disegno una bella occhiata ai
bassifondi della cameriera e ora c'è
crisi per tutti sono contento che il
signor nguyen abbia tenuta la stessa
qualità audio del predecessore
non sia mai che poi il secondo è più
bello del primo e si crea dislivello
basta tenere tutto allo stesso piano e
buonasera
la cosa curiosa è che durante tutto il
dialogo c'è un brusio di sottofondo ma
ha fatto da chi che il locale è vuoto e
si riversa ci sono i vandalismi
lo sapevo scopriamo che la cameriera e
anche un'attrice a tempo perso e lui è
interessato perché un regista ammazza
che coincidenza io di solito incontro
camerieri studenti che fanno fatica ad
arrivare a fine mese ma ad un tratto io
devo sono i protagonisti del primo film
mi fa un sincero effetto di vederli e
come quella sensazione di quando re
incontri dopo tanti anni un tuo compagno
di liceo che però ti sta sul cazzo il
tuo correva in confusione non sai bene
cosa provare dopo aver bevuto una birra
che palesemente che alla pesca
sottomarca tra l'altro decidono di
lavorare insieme al film valentini solo
che al regista gli serve un milione di
dollari
l'amico negli in anticipo a 100.000
perché chi non ha un amico che butta
100mila dollari per un film indipendente
di cui non sa manco la trama gli altri
900.000 cercheranno di prenderli
parlandole alla riunione è la primissima
domanda che i due produttori fallo e
sexy
dove la [ __ ] non vi abbattete signori
potete sempre di farvi col cinema
italiano le mie battute sono sempre
fresche ma dopo essersi rilavorati
ancora un po riescono ad avere i soldi
in secolarizzata l'apatico l'ha fatto
anche il classico pranzo pre produzione
tra il regista e l'attrice in cui giuro
su dio che non ho capito uno schifo di
quello che si sono detti a causa di un
audio chi montini e mostarda veramente
perché è sempre opposta bancari e dulcis
in fundo parte anche il montaggio né
musicale
con la targa oscurata vabbè che low
budget ma non esageriamo
però la cosa mi puzza non sembra siano
in auto per davvero
adesso sì che ci credo solo proprio in
alto e poi si cammina si cammina si
cammina perché girare nei luoghi
affollati se volevi oscurare tutti
sembra un servizio delle iene a metà
spiaggia incontrano l'altra coppietta e
insieme assistono ad una delle cose più
sconvolgenti mai viste siete pronti
avete qualcuno vicino a voi che vi possa
assistere in caso di mancamento
tenetevi forte perché questo è un treno
da cui non si può più scendere
a smettere ma che cazzo mi vuoi far
credere che non avevano i mezzi per fare
una scena sott'acqua e se andate a
cercarvi il backstage del film
scoprirete che è per davvero una ragazza
appesa ad un palo che muove le gambe
davanti un green screen o oggi vediamo
la scena sott'acqua ok anche spiaggia
puoi andare molto alle spiagge la
facciamo in studio ma non sarebbe meglio
che se il regista tu che c'entrano ma
allora dài tutti studio che andiamo a
girare che se mi gira facciamo può
nascere in auto ma aspettate se la
ragazza e la vittima chi è il predatore
vabbè il disagio più totale che poi ci
hanno azzeccato in pieno
e proprio questo quello che vuole vedere
uno che cerca un film di aquile
assassine un poligono forma di medusa la
ragazza viene attaccata e per attaccata
intendo nella mia fantasia ed i nostri
protagonisti chiamano subito
un'ambulanza per aiutarla questa è la
mini ciliegia che sta sopra la ciliegia
che sta sopra una torta di merda che è
questa scena è finta e si è finta non
hanno avuto quanti soldi per
un'ambulanza vero le gambe la medusa
l'ambulanza abbiamo finalmente trovato
la trinità di cui si parla nella bibbia
se la religione fosse un film io starei
già sacrificando una capra grassa come
se non fosse successo assolutamente
nulla
insieme al figlio adottivo dell'ex
attore che appare solo in questa scena e
mai più
vanno al museo preistorico uscendo e
incontrano un loro amico professore
al bambino
vai a giocare più in là ta e non
disturbiamo il professore prof
diamoci una calmata e su un ragazzino
non sa quel che dice e allora sei
stronzo bello che sei stronzo e tra
l'altro questo dialogo non è inteso come
umorismo ma fa proprio parte del
discorso generale
sai cosa manca a questo discorso
antropologico sugli animali preistorici
che cosa dei beni scusi eh sì dei pini
piccoli dei piedi grandi non credo sia
la cosa migliore da facesse
sceneggiatore tu ancora non sono
sceneggiatore ma io voglio dire a loro
tragiche dopo 3 porno da tir di scrivere
che non faccio in tempo il prof spiega
che nella preistoria due uomini
primitivi vennero attaccati da uno
stormo di aquile e morirono proprio qui
dove c'è ora il laghetto perdonatemi se
non vi faccio vedere i flashback adesso
ma me lo tengo per dopo arrivate ad un
locale decidono le ultime cose per il
film e si mettono a ballare
ora voi vedete la recensione con i
dovuti tagli ma non potete immaginare
con quale infinita lunghezza si protrae
insistentemente nella mia vita questa
scena ma l'apocalisse non guarda in
faccia a nessuno e subito dopo aver
iniziato a piovere senza un motivo
apparente
inizia il caos
guardate l'orrore guardate con quale
violenza psicologica i passanti non si
accorgono minimamente di quello che stia
succedendo e pensate la sfiga l'attacco
inizio proprio mentre il 4 stanno
finalmente girando loro film non c'è
neanche bisogno di commentarla cotanta
perfezione il ritorno degli appendiabiti
è un tocco di classe ma la chicca è il
tizio con l'ombrello che ci mette tutta
l'anima per cercare di rendere vivibile
la cosa arrivano anche le guardie di
sicurezza ma senza successo
non ho idea di cosa stia facendo ballo
sto facendo male si salvano solo loro 4
ai due tecnici un bestione è un asiatico
e ad un tratto seni se nisseni 6 per
ovvi motivi non posso farvi vedere molto
sappiate solo che muoiono tutti ed ora
in avanti come una malattia fulminea i
nostri protagonisti non potranno più
fare a meno di dire cislab che feb
ricordati che devi morire
ichino monomero segnano la città e il
subbuglio a causa di quelli che sembrano
kamikaze della seconda
sono confuso ma felice dopo essersi
salvati grazie anche agli incredibili
colpi di kung fu alla telecamera
raggiungono una casetta nel nulla mai
chiusa o kaki una ragazza è rimasta
chiusa dentro provate ad aiutarla ad
uscire a era aperta la porta e non so
cosa dire ha aperto la porta e non
riusciva non so perché la signorina
vestita in modo sobrio si unisce a loro
nella speranza di salvarsi in mezzo alla
foresta incontrano l'abbraccia tore di
alberi del primo film
potrei spiegarvi che lui è un
ambientalista che aveva previsto tutto
che è scampata ad un incendio fatto al
computer che non usa la carta igienica
da anni ma sarebbe inutile perché tutti
ci stiamo chiedendo la stessa cosa che
cazzo di problema hanno i suoi capelli e
parolo cotto alla lorenzo lamas è
talmente inguardabile che più credibile
la medusa dei muri ci avviciniamo al
finale ed i nostri eroi trovano un
camper e si mettono in viaggio per
andare dove
ovvio per girare l'isolato più volte in
cerca di qualcuno da salvare prima tappa
un'auto piena di cadaveri d'armi
nessuna spiegazione rubano le armi e
vanno via
perché sì seconda tappa un cinema
la sala piena di gente viene attaccata
ai loro scappano ma certo tutte le armi
che hanno rubato prima non le possono
usare per sparare ma le azzurre la
collezione del nonno anche quei
poveracci mica potevano scappare dalla
sale salvarsi molto meglio morire senza
un motivo apparente sulle seggiole terza
tappa cimitero qui il protagonista
sono gli zombie in questo film ci sono
gli zombie in questo film
e porta tappa uomini primitivi aspetta
ve la ricordate la scena di flashback
che non vi ho fatto vedere prima il
professore racconta cos'è successo
milioni di anni fa proprio in quel punto
lì a quanto pare 2 homo sapiens sono
stati interrotti sul più bello e sono
morti proprio lì vicino al lago ed
infatti insieme alle abili sono tornati
in vita pure loro
ho bisogno di una botta in testa
no ma solo per confermare che quello che
ho visto oggi sia reale o proprio
bisogno di questa certezza datevi un
secondo riescono a fuggire picchiando a
sangue i due poveracci e a partire per
la loro ultima tappa benzina rimangono a
secco quindi decidono di fermarsi in un
albergo per cercare aiuto
ora insieme a me fate un bel respiro
chiudete gli occhi per cinque secondi e
pensate a qualcosa di bello perché
dovete immagazzinare questa scena che
l'ultima scena del film ed è la
sublimazione dell'arte tutta d'un fiato
si fermano ad un distributore della
pepsi da cui escono due lattine di coca
cola sì ma nell inquadratura subito dopo
nessuno ha una coca ma tutti una birra
si stacco tra un inquadratura e l'altra
e cambiano dell'uomo tutte le lattine
dai così mentre vengono attaccati dalle
aquile nel riflesso del vetro si vede il
cameraman
ci siamo quasi siccome non sanno come
far finire il film
l'asiatico umore e senza motivo le
aquile vanno via per sempre
quasi come se la causa di tutto questo
forse lui nessuna spiegazione
nessun dialogo finale niente di niente
no grazie film ho finalmente capito cosa
posso fare